[Music]
my name is Kenny case crossdresser
I am a diverse video viral video is I
usually have my equipment with me jeez
I'll be honest this being here right now
with you folks is the last thing I want
to be I have had a very rough couple
weeks I just got back from Des Moines I
was there wrapping up a elementary
school or school brain fart Elementary
School tour promoting the environment
through the use of my yo-yoing skills
and it was a major disaster I was in Des
Moines and I would wrapped it up and I
decided to unwind a little bit
and when you're in Des Moines and you're
alone and you're at a bar and you're
just dancing by yourself there will be a
issue there will be problems and they do
not take kindly when you let them know
what you do for a living there because
apparently all they do is farm sorry I
wasn't cut out for farming I come from a
long line of farmers I'm not one of them
and they took all my equipment they took
my yo-yos they took one of my buckets I
was able to save this problem
[Music]
they stole the head microphone that I
usually use so my hands are free usually
and they took my shorts and my t-shirt
and my yellow hat so now I'm wearing
these and they're wrinkled because I
just got back I should though while I'm
up here give a shout-out to Bob Harris
of Harris's Heating and Cooling in Des
Moines Iowa
forgive me out here and at the same time
I want to not give a shout out to Tom
Banasik a Banaszak seeding the cooling
in the wind for doing absolutely nothing
to help me get out who wants to see is
[Applause]
usually I'll do a yo-yo track at this
point I need a volunteer
[Laughter]
I said how'd your hair get so these
lights are very bright
[Laughter]
[Music]
that ladies that's how you yo-yo thank
you I need that I need the bag back
[Laughter]
[Music]
that's usually the end
[Music]